pour part du départ messieurs attention
près aux noms n'ont sûrement pas avec un
éléphant ça trompe énormément
yves robert met en scène une chronique
douce amère des démêlés extraconjugaux
de quatre hommes de 40 ans le personnage
central de cette comédie n'est autre que
jean rochefort jean rochefort que l'on
se plaît à découvrir tous les ans malgré
ses vingt ans de métier j'ai
l'impression que les années ne passe pas
c'est bien de repartir donc commencé
tout le temps mais ça vient peut-être
justement du fait que je joue des
personnages et la chance de jouer des
personnages extrêmement différents alors
peut-être est-ce pour cela que
on découvre à chaque fois mais non pas
maintenant aux panthères cette folle ou
quoi oui oui monsieur le ministre mais
ça sera fait bien sûr vous y allez quand
on parle du cinéma français on dit delon
belmondo peut-être un ou deux autres
pourquoi pas jean rochefort c'est très
aimable je ne sais pas comment répondre
en fait à cette question parce que je
n'appartiens pas je n'ai pas d'abord ce
que je souhaite vraiment moi
j'appartiens à une catégorie de gens qui
étaient à belmondo était ça aussi de
gens de théâtre qui sont venus au cinéma
comme ça parce que ils se sont mis un
petit peu à correspondre à leur époque
et à représenter l'homme typique de 40
ans encore vaguement comestibles
c'est pour ça qu on fait du cinéma et
puis j'ai pris d'un passion du cinéma
maintenant j'adore ça mais au départ moi
j'étais fait pour jouer des vieux des
jeunes des gâteaux des paysans des de
faire l'acteur comme on envisageait de
le faire il ya une vingtaine d'années
comme quand j'étais au conservatoire et
poche donc une anti star des bleus
sortent
non je peux pas dire ça non plus ça
serait profondément malhonnête et
parce que en fait c'est tout de même
merveilleux quand ça a été dur comme
tout le monde dans des années d'avoir
cette possibilité de choix vous savez
d'avoir un éventail de scénarios sur son
petit amas chambre se dire décide
j'ai passé mes enfants je pars pour
s'apitoyer moi mais j'ai passé des pas
mal d'années à me dire mais ça va venir
ou quoi qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce
que tu tu as bien fait faire ce métier
ou quoi qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai
essayé de jouer au mieux la comédie
pendant 15 ans tous les soirs dur
vraiment en somme a été très très dur
alors je dis pas que je cinéma ce sont
des vacances mais y'a une une diversité
de situations par exemple ce matin
j'étais là 25 mètres de hauteur face à
l'arc de triomphe sur une voie corniche
de vram de triomphe en face de moi sont
des situations que je qualifierais pas
de vacances hier mais deux sens et ça
c'est très très
ça
[Musique]